una candidata demócrata dando a luz
apoyando el derecho de la mujer a
decidir sobre su cuerpo en su anuncio de
campaña es uno de los números los
ejemplos mostrando el papel que tomó el
aborto en la política estadounidense;
para los demócratas pronunciarse sobre
este tema tiene un objetivo claro
recordar a sus votantes un derecho
perdido que está en juego en las
elecciones de medio término y ganar
votos en el campo adversario
los demócratas esperan que haya un grupo
suficientemente grande de mujeres de
tendencia republicana y se centran
especialmente en las mujeres blancas con
estudios universitarios cuya política
ideológica no están extrema como la de
otro republicanos que se preocupan por
las cuestiones relacionadas con el
aborto y votarían a los demócratas por
lo que perciben como libertad
reproductiva pero en Estados Unidos la
inflación Ya borró las preocupaciones
por los derechos humanos de ciertos
votantes por eso Muchos candidatos
republicanos hicieron momento el costo
de la vida el centro de sus campañas
echando la culpa a la administración
demócrata de rhodent un argumentó que
comencé en Estados como Ohio entre el
noreste industrial y el medio oeste
agrícola
cuando más dinero se gaste mayor será la
inflación ahora mismo se ve que en el
lado de los demócratas creen que gastar
más dinero va a bajar la inflación lo
cual es completamente ya sabes va en
contra del sentido común de lo que nos
han enseñado desde que éramos niños
en un reciente estudio más del 90% de
los republicanos citan la economía como
la razón más importante para